your you put over the association with
him last time look he's not what we need
I love how he's trying to swat him away
like he's some sort of fly even the
mention of him he's like before the guy
[Music]
finish just imagine the people back in
the day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even yet
what is one thing that they would carry
with them the Quran why because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets brothers and sisters
imagine you have a app the Quran app
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on your that you read it wherever
you
was brothers and sisters and dear
friends we've got some amazing video for
you guys of Nidra farage absolutely
owning Elon Musk yeah yes it's very
interesting because in must been you
know he's on this far right
anti-immigration except the H1B you know
he's are come on come on a you want some
information I'll give it to you so he's
been trying to promote Tommy Robinson as
this you know um Freedom Fighter or
whatever you want to name it you know
he's in prison for the wrong reasons and
n quot as is I was surprised I'm
actually I'm I'm I'm thinking if if
voting was allowed I would be voting for
the Reform Party he's definitely
reformed himself so here is what they
had they had a bit of an exchanger and
obviously um uh you know mus is has been
promoting Tommy Robinson so yeah so Elon
Musk um after hearing Nigel farage's
reply got really upset because he's been
suppoting Tomy Robinson and he said the
following he said the reform party needs
a new leader farage doesn't have no but
you didn't say what farage actually said
though oh you want that you don't want
you want the juicy bit now it's like
it's like you don't want to have your
burger lost you want to have it first
Burger I like it nice double cheese okay
here's what farage said and this is
let's see how Elon Musk replied Robinson
as one of these people that fought
against the grooming gangs um but of
course the truth is Tommy Robinson is in
prison not for that but for contempt of
court for the third occasion so so but I
mean equally there are people in Britain
who think that Robinson is a political
prisoner that's the narrative that he's
pushed out that's how he earns his
living but it isn't quite true would you
accept Robinson as a member of your
party you put ukip over the association
with him last time no no look you know
Robinson has been to prison many many
times for many many things mortgage
fraud passport problems you name it he's
got his own campaign we are a political
party aiming to win the next general
election he's not what we need he's not
what we need I love how he's trying to
swat him away like he's some sort of fly
even the mention of him he's like before
the guy
[Music]
[Laughter]
finish get it away bro he was cold as
and you know what one thing you need to
give to this guy here is that he has has
principles the guy ja Jour has
principles he's not reactionary he's
thinking ahead and he said very clearly
it's just that's how he makes his living
He said look that's how Tom he's speak
up saying look that's how he makes his
living he's just giving this propaganda
this lie that he's a political prisoner
no he's not my friend he's a criminal if
I had that many criminal records bro bro
the fire will be on my case bro passport
fraud you traveled to Canada you got
arrested there yeah for immigration
whatever you have been caught by
undercover officers abusing your wife or
beating her up or whatever that matter
yeah you've been done for a mortgage uh
fraud
my friend you're a fullblown criminal
and and to to add insult to injury
there's at least two videos in which
he's clearly supporting Zionism and the
second video he's he's clearly pissed
out of his skull and he's saying you
know what if tomorrow there was a war
I'd be on the side of his because why
not yeah well I wish he went there you
know he would he would uh maybe get
liquidated yeah and the thing is now
then El must got upset he's like you
faraj was on the same team H no not
really you know he said no no no no no
no no no no
so El musos the reform party needs a new
leader farage doesn't have what it takes
now I need to say something yeah farage
you can see he's level-headed this guy's
an absolute clown clown ELO musk yeah
bro look automatically he's ego is hurt
and he expresses that he cannot control
himself yeah if he was a smart genuinely
a smart man strategic yeah you would not
do that look at him just reactionary the
reform party needs a new leader farage
doesn't have what it takes it's like
somebody upset you oh somebody said that
to me now he's finished so faraj reply
still very level-headed well this is a
surprise Elon is a remarkable individual
but on this I'm afraid I disagree bro he
sounds mature I'm so sorry he sounds
mature my view remains that Tommy
Robinson is not right for reform and I
will never set out my
principles I mean I have to give respect
where it's Jew and you need to give
something to faraj wherever he disagrees
with is that he put Elon Musk in his
place in on a on a different level okay
and I believe for him to support Tommy
Robinson when he went and changed his
whole tune when he went to Israel yeah
they clearly told him who's the Allies
who to support it is not a coincidence
that he's coming and supporting Tommy
Robinson one of the biggest assets
Israel has thees Zionist have for him to
come now and make him a political do you
know what they said support him and this
is exactly what Elon Musk is doing I
don't know if you I don't know if you've
noticed but the mention of Tommy
Robinson in the last few months was Next
To None yes no one was talking about him
it's only because of Elon Musk now that
he's been bought up and put back on the
pedestal and then the far right and all
of these things it's asly as if he was
getting battered for the H1B the whole
visa thing going on in America and he's
losing far right support so a lot of
these things are very strategic but it's
clear that Tommy Robinson Zionist Elon
Musk obviously went there and you know
he's been pushing pushing forward um
certain Zionist figures they P when it
comes to X giving them high positions
and stuff like this and people have been
quite upset and now um pushing forward
Tommy
Robinson what can be said you know I
mean nothing but you can clearly see um
Elon Musk is not your intellectual he
might be smart of making I don't think
he's he someone was telling he didn't
play a PL in the whole rocket thing idea
yeah look he's he's always tweeting like
somebody that's making Rockets you don't
have time to sit on Twitter and tweet
you know what I mean so it's not rocket
science is it well clearly is come
on pun intended you don't ask you finish
we on your case inshah and mhammed hijab
is also been uh systematically
intellectually destroying you anyways
but you're just going to see shown your
true colors and everyone can see it for
that matter if you guys enjoyed the
video guys please share it inshallah may
Allah bless and preserve you guys till
next time